apex legends has gone pocket sized with
apex legends mobile an entirely separate
version of the battle royale game for
android and ios devices apex legends
mobile is quite different from its older
sibling featuring a unique roster maps
modes and progression track some of
which unfortunately detracts from the
overall experience however apex legends
mobile streamlines the process of
playing a battle royale to create a
fairly rewarding experience that's fun
to play
freeloading
apex legends mobile is a battle royale
game first and foremost you and your
squad mates pick from a roster of hero
characters called legends before then
dropping onto a map to win you need to
loot supplies and weapons escape the
encroaching energy wall that slowly
corral squads into an ever dwindling
space and be the last team standing
reloading
when you fall in battle your allies can
grab your banner from the death box you
leave behind and respawn you keeping the
whole team in the fight there's a
satisfying heft to shooting and
smoothness to movement and the unique
strengths and weaknesses of each
playable legend encourages teams to stay
and work together color-coded
attachments and ammo types ensures the
momentum of the match is constantly
moving forward at a glance you know
whether a pile of loot contains anything
you might want or need so you aren't
wasting time navigating menus and can
get back to the action all of this of
course is directly pulled from the
already superb apex legends if it ain't
broke don't try and fix it
the game features two other modes beyond
battle royale arenas and team deathmatch
arenas is a 3v3 mode in which teams
compete in a collection of rounds where
items legend abilities and weapons need
to be purchased with currency at the
start of every match arenas offers a
much higher skill threshold than the
standard battle royale mode as there are
no respawns team deathmatch meanwhile is
far more approachable putting players
into 6v6 matches where you can change
your weapons or legend whenever with
infinite respawns arenas is great team
deathmatch isn't arenas leans into why
the battle royale's combat is so
compelling teams have to work together
intelligently using their firearms
abilities and knowledge of the map to
plan an attack execute and adapt if
necessary none of that exists in team
deathmatch which is your standard
mindless shoot em up game mode seen in
practically every shooter it lacks the
same uniqueness and brand of flavor
respawn is captured in arenas and battle
royale even as an on-ramp for new
players the mode is not compelling since
team deathmatch has to be unlocked and
you'll likely have a few hours under
your belt by the time you do with a
firing range and non-ranked playlist
team deathmatch isn't an ideal warm-up
mode either daily and weekly challenges
are available to further your
progression of both the free and premium
tiers of a battle pass experience points
earned by playing the game contribute to
your player level apex packs unlock
cosmetics for legends and weapons and
there is also the perk system all those
different types of progression are a lot
to keep track of but it ensures that
you're often earning something or
working towards unlocking some sort of
reward with every match you play
most of it is your typical live service
game fair and provides a compelling
enough reason to turn on the game every
day and play a quick match or two though
the perk system in particular presents
an interesting twist in apex legends
mobile playing as a certain legend
that's you points towards unlocking
unique perks for them allowing you to
further customize a character to fit
your ideal playstyle you can make the
speed demon octane even more difficult
to catch by equipping the vomitos perk
for example which gives him a speed
boost if his armor is ever shattered or
dabble in a riskier playstyle with a
stunt mode perk which changes his stem
so it can be toggled on and off allowing
you to maintain your enhanced speed at
the cost of constantly losing health
each character can only be equipped with
three of these perks at a time and
they're divided into categories to
prevent any unfair combinations from
forming at least from what i've seen the
system adds a welcome complexity to
every character in apex legends mobile
none of these perks can fundamentally
alter a legend's place in the meta but
they do add fun considerations in every
match plus perks ensure you're still
feeling a sense of progression and
variety even if you're only playing with
the same two or three characters
regarding characters apex legends mobile
starts with a healthy ensemble of 10 but
only a few are unlocked from the get-go
thankfully you unlock new characters far
faster than you can in apex legends so
you won't be stuck with the same faces
for long interestingly apex legends
mobile has an exclusive legend named
fade fate is a fun character and a much
needed addition for mobile with no cross
progression or cross play between this
game and apex legends having a strong
incentive like a new legend to play
ensures mobile remains a complimentary
choice for long time apex legends
players jumping into this game doesn't
feel like simply starting over in the
literal same experience largely for how
fade affects the in-match meta the only
true downside to his inclusion is that
he contributes to apex legends mobile's
offensive legend overstuffing this is
also an issue in apex legends but is
especially egregious and mobile where
half of the starting roster is geared
towards attacking other teams whereas
apex legends control scheme is designed
in a way to encourage players to use the
ping system apex legends mobile is at
least mechanically more focused around
the fact that players can only play with
their thumbs as such all inputs need to
be condensed so you can play with just
two fingers apex legends mobile
implements some smart quality of life
improvements to streamline the mechanics
of its battle royale the game is never
playing for you victory remains a
rewarding result as it is still largely
determined by individual skill in a
squad's teamwork instead apex legends
mobile automates the process of looting
death boxes for example quickly grabbing
the attachments and ammo that fit your
equipped guns if you want to slowly
scroll through a death box contents for
grenades extra healing or attachments
you can't use right now but may want to
hold on to for later you still can but
apex legends mobile speeds up that
process for anyone who may not be
dexterous enough to do so in the midst
of a firefight features like this ensure
the small amount of real estate
available on a smartphone screen isn't
wasted on buttons that may not add as
much to the experience as the actual
shooting though most are aimed at
speeding up the looting process allowing
you to get back to the fight as quickly
as possible a few exist on the combat
side as well for instance you
automatically aim down sights when
shooting removing the hassle of needing
to press and hold down an additional
button while trying to hit a target
that's further away playing on the
screen is still not an ideal setup this
is a fast-paced shooter after all and a
touchscreen just isn't as responsive as
a good old-fashioned gamepad plus even
on a substantially sized phone screen i
played on a samsung galaxy s10 i still
accidentally fire my gun on occasion
when i only mean to look around
everything is just so close together
that if my thumb drifts even a little i
accidentally pull the trigger and if my
teammate's habit of randomly firing into
the air or at a wall where there is no
enemy as any indication i'm not the only
one accidentally doing this in a game
like apex legends mobile where
conserving your ammo is crucial and
ensuring enemies you're sneaking up on
can't hear you shooting when you don't
mean to is frustrating support for every
gamepad controller and handheld
attachment isn't available at launch
barismon says full support is coming
eventually like the switch version of
apex legends apex legends mobile
compromises on graphical detail draw
distance and the speed at which assets
are loaded in order to run on android
and ios devices this means long
precision weapons are harder to use
especially with touch screen controls
which unfortunately favors the meta
towards needing automatic and
semi-automatic firearms in order to win
regular frame rate issues also persist
often dipping when you're redeploying
bouncing off a jump pad or traveling on
a zipline apex legends mobile can also
stutter if multiple squads are fighting
within the same enclosed space
unlike the switch version apex visions
mobile does not support cross play with
the xbox playstation and pc versions of
apex legends so these technical issues
aren't as drastic a problem however
these issues are annoying whenever they
pop up brief as they may be and become
frustrating when the result is a miss
shot or poorly timed dodge overall apex
legends mobile is exactly what's being
advertised this is apex legends but on
mobile devices this means respawn has
made some serious concessions to its
battle royale in order to make the whole
thing work especially when it comes to
visuals and performance and not all of
the new additions to the formula like
team deathmatch and anything compelling
but the perk system and first mobile
exclusive legend create a strong draw
for apex legends mobile to exist
alongside apex legends as a companion
game if you want to play apex legends on
the go this fulfills that need just
don't come into it thinking this is the
best way to play reespan's battle royale
game
[Music]
squad